[Music]
austin is with us in boise idaho austin
welcome to the ramsay show
hi george how are you i'm doing great
how are you man how can i help
um so i'm a junior in high school and i
mow lawns around my neighborhood
and so i've saved up about twenty seven
thousand dollars whoa it's just sitting
in my bank account dude way to go and
i don't know what to do with it because
i know i'm gonna go to college in a
couple of years and so i'll probably
need some of it but my dad also has
a 529 account for me and that has he's
predicting it'll have about 40 to 45 000
in it
in a couple of years when i go to go to
college and i'm also
planning on serving a two-year mission
for my church after my first year of
college dude
the expenses for that mission are only
400 a month so i'm definitely not going
to need all my money
immediately of course i'll use it to go
to college debt free but i was just
wondering should i be investing it
should i have in just a high yield
savings account like i have which really
isn't that high yield
in fact it's very low yield yeah or
should i put it in a certificate of
deposit or is there something i should
be doing with my money that i'm not
already
uh well first of all you are crushing it
i mean you many americans are like this
kid's a junior in high school and he's
doing better than me financially it's
time to make a change
and your dad has got a great head on his
shoulders it's so awesome that he's got
that 529 set up for you and he's
throwing money in there uh so yeah what
i would do with that money you're doing
the right thing putting in a high-yield
savings account because
this is money that you may need in the
next year or two years right
yeah so i wouldn't go investing this
into uh into the market right now
because you've got a short time horizon
where you may need this money so your a1
is investing in austin right now which
you're doing a great job of you are you
have you're not scared of work and so
you've got this 27k i want to make sure
that you can go to college debt-free do
you have plans to definitely go to
college
yeah i do
we're at do you have any idea
well i was hoping byu that's an option
or montana state or i could stay close
to home and go to boise state that's
right in the backyard love it so we're
talking in-state affordable schools here
yeah boise state would be in state and
byu is pretty cheap montana state would
be the
dream if i could get a scholarship there
yeah i mean i think at this point apply
for all the scholarships you can but be
ready to pay for it in cash and choose
the most affordable option make sure
that your your
education matches your goal do you know
what you want to study
uh some kind of engineering i think i'd
like mechanical engineering to sound
cool but no i'm not completely sure
fantastic we'll start to dig into that
and see what it's like maybe you shadow
a mechanical engineer for a day and go
wow i love this or oh my gosh i can't
imagine having to do this every day
so you've got time to figure that out
and you've got a nice pile of money
between the 529 and your money here i'm
i'm counting up
72 000 dollars
that you guys have right now
that you could use towards your
education i know you said you've got
that mission piece that you want to do
for two years and that's about five
grand a year give or take
uh which you're obviously going to cash
flow so uh how you use the money i think
we're going to use that towards college
and if we're not sure yet i would still
park it in that high yield savings
account keep throwing money in that 529
through your dad that's awesome
and then once you get through college we
can see what's left over
you might need it all right or you might
have 20 grand left over and then you can
use that towards your emergency fund you
can use that to start investing use that
as a down payment on your first house
all kinds of life goals but i would not
put it in anything riskier than a high
yield savings account right now i know
it's sad you're like it's growing at 5.5
percent this sucks
that's okay yeah the best thing you can
do is keep investing in austin keep
growing that uh savings that you have
right now it's so awesome you get the
side hustle and it's crushing man way to
go happy to hear it
thanks keep us posted on the journey man
did you hear that america a junior in
high school
has a higher net worth than most of you
i'm not here to shame you
but i am here to tell you that we could
do better
and that there is hope in the next
generation don't tell me that gen z
sucks
austin's crushing it this kid's a
unicorn
we all should aspire to be like this guy
so much good stuff happening there happy
to hear austin's story i want more of
that
in 2022 i'm here for it